die Medien haben natürlich insgesamt bei
in der ganzen corona-zeit eine ganz ganz
große Rolle gespielt und leider keine
allzu gute weil sie sehr aktiv
Ängste geschürt haben weil sie später
auch massiv sozusagen die Menschen dazu
getrieben haben oder auch bewegt haben
sich impfen lassen zu müssen und weil
auch Fakten teilweise nicht hinterfragt
wurden die wurden sozusagen
unreflektiert weitergegeben
weitergetragen und
ja leider sozusagen gibt es in diesem
Zusammenhang ich ich befasse mich schon
seit vielen Jahren mit medizinthemen und
auch mit den Akteuren in der Medizin
leider muss man sagen dass es gerade
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk der
ja eigentlich eine Vorbildfunktion in
Sachen Unabhängigkeit kritische Distanz
zu den Akteuren spielen sollte dass der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk da
versagt hat in vielen Stellen muss man
wirklich sagen und das hat auch Gründe
und diese Gründe
habe ich mich auch aktuell ein bisschen
genauer damit befasst
sind Interessenkonflikte also das
bestimmte Journalisten Aufträge also
gleichzeitig als Journalist tätig sind
für den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
beispielsweise natürlich auch gibt es
auch im Printbereich oder bei den
privaten Fernsehsendern aber wie gesagt
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
sollte eigentlich frei von
Interessenkonflikten der Journalisten
sein und da hat sich gezeigt dass doch
ein erheblicher eine erhebliche Zahl von
Journalisten sich auch in der
corona-zeit und teilweise davor von von
der Regierung von der Bundesregierung
von Bundesministerien hat bezahlen
lassen und nicht nur im Bund sondern
auch in länderbereich und
ja auch eine große Geschichte von ihnen
im Cicero die sie uns heute auch
exklusiv mitgebracht haben und da geht
es um eckart von Hirschhausen was werfen
sie ihm vor also er ist ein Beispiel es
geht mir jetzt nicht darum Hirschhausen
Bashing zu machen aber
dann es gibt andere die ähnlich agieren
aber er hat ist eben zu seinem sehr
dominanten Gesicht auch geworden in
dieser corona-zeit weil er ein
vehementer Befürworter der Impfung war
und weil er seine Rollen in dieser Zeit
wahnsinnig vermischt hat und das hat
also von Unabhängigkeit kann da leider
überhaupt gar nicht die Rede sein denn
Herr von hirschenhausen arbeitet zum
Teil oder zum einen für die ARD hat
Beiträge gemacht über Corona ganz zu
Anfang eigentlich direkt nach dem ersten
Lockdown kam schon eine Sendung wo es
eben um die Problematik der
Intensivstationen gegen und da wurden
eigentlich die Ängste der der Menschen
noch mal mit befördert wie schlimm das
wohl alles werden wird und später hat er
dann auch Beiträge gebracht als es dann
um das Thema Impfung ging um die
Bereitschaft der Menschen zur Impfung zu
fördern und das ist nicht Aufgabe eine
Journalisten da als Aktivist sozusagen
alternativ zu werden sondern ein
Journalist insbesondere ein
Wissenschaftsjournalist muss die Fakten
vollständig wiedergeben nicht einen Teil
weglassen und dadurch ein verzerrtes
Bild erzeugen und er muss unabhängig
sein er darf keine eigenen Interessen in
dem Bereich haben und meine Recherchen
haben eben gezeigt dass da massive
Interessenkonflikte vorliegen also zum
einen hat sich Herr von Hirschhausen zum
Beispiel bezahlen lassen von der von dem
von der Bundesregierung also vom
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
beispielsweise wurde das Impfbuch für
alles so hieß ein kleines Büchlein
erstellt wo er auch sein Name sozusagen
die Titelseite mit schmückt und dafür
hat er natürlich Geld bekommen zwar wird
es erstmal geleugnet vom
Gesundheitsministerium wenn man
nachfragt aber wenn man nachfragt stellt
man fest ja über die Agentur dieses Buch
gemacht hat hatte eben dann doch Geld
bekommen was ich auch wieder fragwürdig
finde was die Rolle des
Gesundheitsministeriums betrifft
dann auch sagen wir mal gibt es
persönliche Verflechtungen
beispielsweise wenn ein Journalist wie
Herr von Hirschhausen per Du ist mit
einem Politiker wie Herr Lauterbach dann
finde ich das schwierig wenn er dann in
dem ARD Beitrag vorgibt nicht per Du zu
sein und die Distanz die ein Journalist
haben muss ja die wird eigentlich den
Zuschauer vorgegaukelt und es geht noch
weiter dass eben Herr von Hirschhausen
immer wieder auch gebucht wird für
ärztekongresse die eben teilweise von
Pharmafirmen mit finanziert werden
Pfizer biontech wir wissen der Wirkstoff
da ist schon eine sehr Verdächtige Nähe
und das gipfelt eigentlich darin dass er
selber
also Geld angenommen hat beispielsweise
von der geldstiftung will und Melinda
geht Stiftung
und zwar 1,8 Millionen US-Dollar für die
Stiftung die er im März 2020 gegründet
hat und noch mehr er ist Gesellschafter
einer immer die ganz offiziell
Lobbyarbeit macht im lobby-rick ist da
eingetragen ist und die unter anderem
für fallsa tätig ist das finde ich schon
also das ist in der Reihe von Vorwürfen
muss man sagen steht morgen alles im
Ziel zurück kann man da also auch noch
mal sich im Detail anschauen ich will
sie haben auch gesagt wir wollen keinen
Bashing gegen eine Person wollen aber
doch mal hinterfragen wie dort
Verpflichtungen und auch
Interessenskonflikte entstehen da hat
man sie sind auch ein bekanntes Gesicht
der öffentlich-rechtlichen können Sie
die Kritik die hier aufgeworfene ähm
wurde gerade verstehen teilweise ich
kenne Ecke von Hirschhausen lange Zeit
und die Bezeichnung Journalist war mir
bisher fremd sage ich Ihnen ganz offen
als wirklich ganz Journalisten
und Comedian da gehst du die Grenzen ja
Fliesen mittlerweile und hat da
wunderbar unterhaltsame Programme in
großen Häusern gespielt
mit hat natürlich mit seiner
medizinischen Kenntnis gespielt da
können Sie das Glück da sein und und und
und dann habe ich schon den Wandel
mitbekommen dass er plötzlich für die
ARD so quasi der Hausarzt wurde und
Ratschläge aus seiner medizinischen
Sicht wie ist völlig neu was sie jetzt
mir erzählen von Spenden über die
Stiftung über Mitarbeit und und und
ich muss das auch sagen ich will hier
auch aufräumen wir zwei sind auch per Du
weil er ist viel zu Präsident des SC
Paderborn und im Sport geht das
einfacher und wollen wir hier nichts
vorgegeben sonst komme ich in die
nächste Sendung ja ich habe auch für
Weißbier Reklame gemacht bei Rudi Völler
ein wunderbaren Satz gesagt hat und eine
Power Paulaner Brauerei im Münchner hat
gesagt der ist schön der ist weiß für
Botschafter also
ich bin dazwischen ja ich werfe keinen
Stein außer was ich zuletzt als Argument
gebracht haben damit macht er sich
angreifbar und die ARD macht sich
unglaubwürdig das macht sie aber nicht
zum ersten Mal wir erleben gerade in
Medienhäusern Überraschungen wo ich auch
sage hätte ich nie gedacht im letzten
oder vorletzten Spiegel eine Hymne über
Seiten über Herrn Pistorius
wo ich mir gedacht habe oh der ist ja
direkt vom Himmel gefallen ist ja
Wahnsinn
und super und toll und dann kommt ein
paar Tage später raus dass die Tochter
des hauptautors redenschreiberin bei
Herrn Pistorius ist wenn ich dem Spiegel
nicht zugetraut und so können wir ein
Beispiel nach dem anderen aus der
Medienlandschaft nehmen
glauben sie auch besonders während der
corona-zeit ein Thema war das zu wenig
Debatte geführt wurde das zu wenig
Stimmen zugelassen wurden die eine
andere Meinung in dieses Thema
reingebracht haben und das glaube ich ja
irgendwie hätte ich das Gefühl ist kam
vor allen Dingen diejenigen zu Wort die
gesagt haben die lockdowns müssen noch
viel härter sein und diejenigen zu Wort
die Corona ganz geleugnet haben aber
dazwischen gab es sehr viele die
kritisch waren und die kam zu wenig vor
zu uns insgesamt bei den Debatten so du
hast das Gefühl dass die Mitte dieses
Landes ich sage jetzt mal so die die
bürgerlichen die sich an die Gesetze
halten an die Regeln die vielleicht zu
langweilig sind für die Schlagzeile in
der Zeitung zu wenig vorkommen das ist
eine Sache und die zweite Sache ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk ich meine
das ist ja offenkundig war gestern Abend
den Erfurt auf einer Veranstaltung da
waren glaube ich zwei oder drei Fragen
zu diesem Thema so und da gibt es eine
ein eine glaubwürdigkeitsfrage und wir
brauchen hier eine Reform also kann
nicht sein dass wir Doppel und dreifach
Strukturen haben und ich sag mal jeder
Bürger muss den Euro umdrehen die
Unternehmen müssen schauen die
Handwerker ich habe das Beispiel eben
gebracht die zum Teil zu machen weil sie
ersticken unter Bürokratie und deswegen
ist der öffentlich rechtliche Rundfunk
auch wirklich gefordert jetzt auch
wirklich diese Strukturform zu machen
dass die Politik sich Hirschhausen
gekauft hat also auch da dann
ja kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht zu
sagen der Fall ist mir neu ich finde
immer das sagt der Informat das ist auch
alles zu sehen also mich freuen uns das
alles sehen es ist überhaupt nicht
verdeckt und vielleicht auch noch mal
ein Punkt dazu ich will jetzt gar nicht
wie gesagt Bashing einer einzelnen
Personen machen es gibt durchaus auch
noch andere Gesichter bei der ARD und
auch beim ZDF wo es sich lohnt genauer
hinter die Kulissen zu gucken ich finde
viel problematisch problematischer
eigentlich die Rolle der ARD und das ZDF
wie Sie mit diesen Dingen umgehen mein
Eindruck ist es besteht überhaupt kein
keine Ahnung davon was
Interessenkonflikte sind und dass die
sich verbieten also das hat z.B auch bei
meiner Recherche gezeigt die Nachfrage
was ist denn in den Augen der den
Interessenkonflikt und da kam nichts
wirklich brauchbares bei raus und
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich auch
gefragt wissen Sie Bescheid über die
Interessenkonflikte oder
Nebentätigkeiten von Herrn von
Hirschhausen ja alles offengelegt sprich
die ARD oder in speziell in der WDR für
den Herr von Hirschhausen insbesondere
tätig ist ist offenbar in absoluter
Kenntnis aller Nebentätigkeiten alle
Interessenkonflikte und ignoriert sie
erstens dürfte Herr von Hirschhausen zu
diesen Themen Corona die irgendwie mit
mit Pharmafirmen zu tun hat überhaupt
keinen Beitrag machen aus meiner Sicht
und das andere ist er müsste auch wenn
ein anderen Rollen wären wäre und alle
anderen seine Kollegen auch Interessen
Konflikte transparent offenlegen für
jeden Zuschauer das wäre möglich
erstaunlicherweise hat ein solchen
Vorschlag sogar ein Mitarbeiter
des NDR gemacht Markus Grill aber die
ARD viele der Verantwortlichen der
Redakteure und auch der Intendanten
offenbar ist eine riesige Naivität eine
Blindheit gegenüber diesen Thema und
wenn wir nämlich dann mal den Bogen
schlagen zur Politik der Fall reichen
und die Vetternwirtschaft und
Interessenkonflikte
man kann schlecht sozusagen die dann an
den Pranger stellen wenn man selber eine
dreckige Weste hat also
insofern finde ich erfüllt der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk überhaupt
nicht mehr die Funktion die er
eigentlich hat nämlich unabhängig zu
sein kritische Distanz Vielfalt die hat
nämlich überhaupt nicht stattgefunden
bei der Corona Diskussion Staatsferne
findet nicht statt Transparenz findet
nicht statt und
unterdessen aber ist der öffentlich
rechtliche Rundfunk auch im Vergleich
zum Beispiel zu BBC und anderen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Systemen absolut
hypertrophiert würde man sagen in der
Biologie also viel zu groß geworden
durch viel zu Geld übersättigt in sich
abgekapselt und nicht mehr effizient
nicht mehr unabhängig und in der Form
finde ich kann der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundung nicht weiter bestehen ich bin
grundsätzlich für die Idee durchaus zu
haben ich finde die gut aber nicht so
wie es gemacht wird und es ist über die
Jahre Jahrzehnte entstanden und ab und
zu kommt wie so eine Alter tolle Frau
Schlesinger oder sonst jemanden aus ja
also
ein Einwurf ich stimme in vielen Teilen
ihn zu aber man sollte dann auch und sie
tun das ja oder geben sofort genau
hinschauen
in der ARD ich war auch lange Zeit ich
war sechs Jahre reaktionsleiter da habe
ich keine Werbung machen dürfen oder
ähnliches aber dann war ich freier
Mitarbeiter Hirschhausen ist freier
Mitarbeiter er muss das Anmelden was er
macht aber der Sender hat kaum
Eingriffsmöglichkeiten weil er freier
Mitarbeiter ist